[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
oh my Lord we're back hey kids it's me
Kevin Smith and I'm Mark Bernard and
welcome to fat man beyond man with Mark
and Kevin how are you uh we're this week
Mark and Pugsley as you can see I'm
wearing
most publicly shared again I know
Wednesday took off so I'm trying to make
Pugsley happen
will it into being exactly man
um how how are you kids uh long time no
see
um stories to tell but for another time
but uh I can say this
this is the first uh fat man beyond
that I've done not stoned
so I am present quit smoking weed it was
five weeks yesterday so I am I'm crisp
and very here kids very alert welcome
aboard
is this what the show's like
what the what the [__] what have we been
doing for these 10 years oh my God it
was so much easier and more fun when I
was stoned
um I uh to start us off the right way I
uh went to a Cardiologist appointment
today I saw my cardiologist uh because I
just passed the five-year anniversary of
the heart attack
and uh they did like they put me on the
treadmill and [__] like that and uh then
put you know jizz on me and did an
ultrasound on my [__] heart and stuff
is that what we're calling it now uh he
said at one point he handed me a bunch
of paper ties to clean yourself I felt
very dirty
that's the same way they do ultrasound I
don't play these bellies
and the heart is doing well and uh you
know I was like how'd I do and he's like
you gotta talk to your doctor and I did
like three minutes later and he was like
you have no blockage whatsoever I was
like
outstanding now that could go hand in
hand with the fact that I am
at my adult
thinnest uh I weigh 180 pounds Mark
which when I was a senior in high school
I weighed 185 pounds so
I'm beating that 17 year old Kevin Smith
at age 52 at least weight-wise fantastic
good for you down down and wait no weed
no fun
but still alive which apparently could
be a good thing depending on who you ask
um how you been Captain uh I'm doing
well man it's it's it's a busy season
here in the in the Bernardin household
um work is going well on the thing that
you and I are doing together that we
still can't talk about
um talk about it like I have no idea
like I you invited me on this Good Ship
Lollipop and I don't know what the rules
are
I'm here I don't know if we could say
who we're working for but the production
company because I remember they
announced this like a long time ago
there was an article
um uh we've been working with the folks
at Wild brain
um putting together 10 episodes of a
Green Hornet cartoon kids that's what me
and Mark have been working on
um it's fun as [__] the animation is
[__] phenomenal it's like that Pixar
[__] it ain't 2D is it's like they took
a 2d drawing and blew it up
and so all the characters look like
balloons um so we've been working on
that can't say who it's potentially for
um but you know once we hand in our
scripts which is what the end of March
or whatever I think so we're getting
close
uh then we'll know whether or not the
people who paid for the scripts want to
move forward with the show knock wood I
I truly hope they do I think we've done
something really cool with it uh
so that's what we've been working on
together are you working on secret stuff
that you haven't talked about
um I'm working on a little bit of secret
stuff I'm in the in the like I'm in the
phase where my agents and managers will
send me uh things to consider right like
hey do you want to take a swing at this
book read this book you want to read
this comic book do you want to read this
magazine article no I thought I thought
you meant things consider like hey would
you like you know to go by suck a dick
and you're like consider
consider tasteful pass
I feel like but you did say tasteful
son of a [__]
people are handing you books and [__]
being like you want to take a crack you
want to take a crack of this did do you
spark to this does it do you have a take
on this and so it's been a lot of
reading stuff giving thoughts on stuff
um and then having the people who own it
decide if they want that version of it
um you know and it's it's always this
weird dance of they're trying to be nice
in offering it to you you're trying to
be nice and responding to them and
whatever you respond may or may not be
what they want anyway and so like it's
it's it can be futile work it's free
work at the moment but you know some of
the stuff is fun some of this stuff is
kind of cool
um so I'm supervising another writer
who's working on on a pilot so that's
fun and it's been Film Festival season
man like we had our first film festival
premiere of Splinter yeah out of here
when did that happen we did and it was
at the pan-african film festival
um a couple of weeks ago here in Los
Angeles
um the 33rd annual pan-african Film
Festival started by among other people
Danny Glover to help uh expand the
diaspora and and and open his arms to
everything that
um that black filmmakers were doing from
all over the world
and uh and Splinter given that I'm a
black filmmaker
um made it to that was waiting Premiere
what yeah man yeah it's a whole thing I
was so how was it
um it was it was a really interesting
experience because I've I've screened it
for the cast and crew so I know how you
know they feel about it and I'm also
sure that some of the crew never read
the script so I think something that was
a surprise to them it's like oh that's
what you were doing okay that's cool
um
but these were the first strangers who
ever saw it
and so like the jokes that are there
worked you know they were oohs and Oz
where they're supposed to be oohs and Oz
you know there was Applause that felt
genuine by the end of it
um there were good questions at the Q
and A's on the back side
um it was a really it's a humbling
experience as I'm sure you well know of
you know putting art into the world and
and letting randos
um and in some cases not randoms a
couple of La based um Kickstarter
backers came to the to the to the Pan
African Film Festival screening so they
got to see it before the other
Kickstarter backers have
um which and I'm sorry everybody I'm
sorry sorry but because of the politics
of the film festival circuit
um the the they frown on Films having
been digitally distributed
ever
um and so that's the reason why we're
withholding the print from the backers
simply to give us a better chance of
getting into film festivals which is
working because now we just got accepted
into the Overlook Film Festival
which is a genre based mostly horror
film festival in New Orleans Louisiana
uh the end of March beginning of April
so I'm going to be going down there with
some members of the cast and the crew
and we're not a good ass [__] time in
The Big Easy showing our silly little
Thriller shorts check you out man so is
that why you [__] shaved because you
have to go to film festivals I I shaved
because I was trying to be a good boy
and uh and uh experience the joys and
wonders of manscapes newest uh product
what a Segway what an amazing segue kids
uh as always we don't come to you unless
somebody comes to us and says here's
money so the good folks uh at manscaped
will be tonight's sponsor man we all
love the good Folks at manscaped uh
they've been back in this show since oh
way back in the day and very exciting
news as Mark has indicated with his
freshly shorn face uh manscape now sells
beard products go figure man it ain't
just for your balls anymore now it's for
your being to be fair they you know as
Mark pointed out before you could always
use the ball trimmer on the on the head
and face but now it's a product directly
for Men's Grooming man revolutionizing
Men's Grooming with the brand new beard
hedger Pro kit from a beard trim to a
fresh shave that technology behind the
beard hedger Pro kit allows you to shape
your signature beard look man AKA this
or in Mark's case you just take it all
the [__] off now you finally use
manscape products to make your drapes
match your carpet by going to
manscaped.com and using the code Fatman
20 all one word for twenty percent off
and free shipping man uh tell us how the
beard hedger Works Mark well I'll tell
you man it's it all starts with the
beard hedger this thing is a juggernaut
of fixing faces first off this cordless
trimmer has a rotary wheel that gives
you 20 hair cutting lengths all with one
guard so no more messy drawers full of
add-ons and clips and [__] that's right
face grooming doesn't get need to be
hard get 20 different beard links in
just one guard and that's what happened
to me because I expected I'm like oh
look it's a [__] dial and I'll go to
the lowest one how low could that
actually be and when I used it it was
skin
Oh [__] okay this is how we're doing
this now okay okay good to know
to the [__] Brazilian smoothie you're
open for the landing strip but look at
you all I was hoping for a little
[__] you know Crockett and tubs and
instead I just got bald eagle
um is it a device that can be used in
the shower Mark is it waterproof it you
know all reports uh indicate yes it is
any waterproof so you can shower in the
shed you can shave in the shower to
avoid all that hair in the sink titanium
coated tea blade is tough on air but
smooth on your face leading to a single
stroke efficiency and it brings
satisfaction one stroke at a time and
titanium kids is the real world
vibranium very much is and they're
putting that [__] on [__] razors you
could buy from manscaped you guys
it's nuts movie Tech first uh there is
the beard shampoo and conditioner you
need to remember all your hair is
different your beard hair is more coarse
and easier to damage than the hair on
your head if you got any left that's why
the kit has made shampoo and conditioner
specifically designed to moisturize
reduce ingrown hairs replace natural
oils and promote beard Health overall
beard Health man next the kid has
manscapes beard oil essential piece for
your main facial accessory man no one
wants a guy who's beard is brittle and
dry
the oil relieves dryness both on the
beard and the skin beneath while adding
a little Shimmer and shine making you
look extra fine I wish I could take copy
uh take credit for the rhyme but that's
right in the copy cap off the kit with
the beard bomb b-a-l-m not b-o-m-b a
Pomade that shapes Styles moisturizes
and tames for a sculpted look to attract
any fellow closed captioning not
available
it's a lot of math I didn't realize
we've been doing so much math tonight
but okay I love those [__] manscape
folks man they're they're doing the
Lord's work and this is this is a
powerful tool you guys like do not wield
lightly the the badger hedger Pro kit
whatever they're gonna call it because
it's it's a lightsaber for your face and
you know do not do not just go add in
the copy it's a lightsaber for your
faces
that's a pretty damn great copy right
there it's an elegant tool from a more
civilized age
folks we thank the good people at
manscape for sponsoring this here
episode of fat man beyond uh visit them
and now it ain't just for your balls
anymore man you don't have to be all
about your nuts to use manscape now you
just go all Bernard and smooth and [__]
okay I mean I don't know how long I'm
Gonna Keep it this way because my face
still feels weird like it's drafty I
feel like it's exposed
you are you're so naked you're so yeah
it's like what I feel like a shield
whatsoever man you're just like the food
just Falls right off my face
ain't no beer no to catch it there's
nothing
um he said I'm debating whether or not
I'm going to keep it shorn for the Ides
of Mark my friend oh my God what a great
you're the king of the Segway tonight
kids
um I'm in Los Angeles at the moment but
I uh am uh in Jersey uh a lot lately
over at smod Castle Cinemas in Atlantic
Highlands and um we have uh a bunch of
stuff uh coming up man uh Saturday night
um where am I oh I'm in uh astronomicon
in Detroit but Saturday night in New
York City are you on the East Coast are
you New Jersey New York Pennsylvania
um our good friend Dr Josh Rausch is
showing wrong reasons at Cinema Village
um it's the end of his tour he's been
touring the movie uh by himself up and
down and whatnot DIY style uh he made it
with a crew of five people and he's torn
it with a crew of one himself man so go
supports the mini film uh it's New York
City on March 4th 11 p.m at Cinema
Village uh tickets at fine cat
odin.com uh meanwhile I'll be in Detroit
unfortunately I wish I was there for the
screening final screening I'm going to
be in Detroit at astronomicon if you're
in the Detroit area not Detroit but near
Detroit
uh however the next day March 5th I'm
back in New Jersey and we're doing Fat
Man on Batman the film series that I do
there and we're showing mask of the
Phantasm
all right right and afterwards I'll get
up chit chat about it and stuff uh the
uh the good Folks at Warner Brothers
uh we wanted to do uh Batman Returns
because we did you know Batman not too
long ago months ago
but because of The Flash movie coming up
Warner Brothers has put a [__]
cease
not seasoned desist but they're like you
can't do Michael Keaton Batman they're
saving it for like June I guess so but
they were goodly enough to be like you
can do mask of the Phantasm so oh my
Lord watching that on the big screen uh
I even started promoting it we already
sold like 50 tickets so people people
want to see old [__] on the big screen
man I is trust me as a guy who owns a
movie theater and stuff I got all sorts
of data now about what people want to
watch we had Avatar our first week man
12 people in the seven o'clock show we
showed the Muppet Movie last month 190
people
came to watch The Muppet Movie and I
think that has probably a lot to do with
a who doesn't love the Muppet movie but
B
everyone's like drowning in content
right now there was a sketch on SNL a
couple weeks ago where they were doing
this movie game show and they asked them
questions about recent movies and nobody
knew [__] like you know you could ask
all the 80s 90s 2000s movies but
currently there's just so much content
that nothing is becoming somebody's
fave or something like that it seems
however the old stuff Never Dies so
Muppet movie Mask of the Phantasm and
the films that we'll be playing during
the Ides of Mark as of March 15th ladies
and gentlemen that is the Ides of Mark
March and uh for that we're celebrating
with uh Mr Mark Bernard here for uh The
Ides of Mark that's podcast Cinemas now
what does that mean that means Mark's
curated three films that he's gonna show
uh the first night is March 15th as
Wednesday and we're showing uh Dune
David Lynch tune the David Lynch dude
not that froofy new uh dude by Denny
vilnu we're talking about the old school
all I see is in a tradies I want to kill
uh you know sting in a in a a plastic
bikini I will kill him yeah uh more deep
my name is a killing word yeah man we're
going deep one of the movies that me and
Mark always talk about on this show so
Mark chose that for the beginning of
odds of Mark that's the March 15th yeah
at 7 p.m tickets it's
modcastlecinemas.com and then afterwards
we'll chit chat about it yeah
um March 16th we're doing uh Streets of
Fire
another Mark chosen flag this is a
wonderful musical if you've never seen
it uh Ellen aim and the attackers uh a
young Diane uh Lane right yeah is that
her last name yeah that's a different
one that's a different one all together
uh with a young um Amy Madigan is that
her name yeah it's Willem dafose
on-screen debut that's right Willem
Dafoe being the first time he ever
played a villain and I guess it is his
on-screen yeah his first time full of
Music Rick Rick Moranis in this
[__] what's the guy's name
Michael Perry right Michael Perry is the
lead we love this movie man it's a movie
of the 80s that we absolutely adored MTV
pushed this movie [__] so hard this
summer it came out yeah directly I've
never seen it on the big screen are you
[__] me yeah I only ever saw it on
VHS oh this is awesome what a great
opportunity kids come on out March 16th
Walter Hills uh Streets of Fire playing
at smilecastle Cinemas part of the odds
of Mark and then Friday night the 17th
which is also St Patrick's Day isn't it
it is
um we are showing two count them two
things that night one is a movie and the
other is a damn show first up Flash
Gordon kids
the original Marvel movie even though he
wasn't a Marvel hero but a very bright
very Poppy
disappointed Millions
the Lost millions of dollars Dino
DiLaurentis that is worth
um this is a all-time classic for those
of us who uh grew up in that era
um so we're showing that at what like
six or seven or something it said five
or five change too
um and that it might have changed a
little bit later because then after that
kids we're doing uh fat man beyond for
the very first time at smodcast Castle
uh Cinemas we did it once like zooming
Mark in at the old smod castle we're
gonna be there right there on stage man
have you ever wanted to be in the room
while this was happening and we're not
at you know this coming villain Cantina
those on the West Coast
have been able to see us in persons
close enough to throw a rolled up tissue
out and shatter our noses well now
you're gonna have the chance to do the
same thing on the East Coast man at
smodcast Castle Cinemas uh on March 17th
that will close out the odds of Mark and
then on March 18th Mark's going to Jay
and Silent Bob's secret stash a 26 year
old brick and mortar comic book store in
Red Bank New Jersey we're going to be
doing a signing of Adora and the
distance indeed and whatever else Mike
zapcik has been able to to harvest from
the ethers but we're there for Adora
we're there for whatever bring whatever
you want me to sign I'll sign it I think
that's from 12 to three kids so the odds
of Mark are upon us and if you know
you're an East coaster who's like man I
never get any [__] Bernardin sent my
way oh you're about to get it man do we
have that hard work Banff man is there
an artwork did I send you artwork to
send a to put up it's a really nice
piece of course done by our very own
dark neighborhood it's Batman everybody
which oh yeah Arts of Mark here we are
look at that look at it look at it and
all this
Greco-Roman Glory he looks like Pluto
from Animal House
uh kids that's a movie that came out in
the 70s
um look at that look at the lineup Dune
Streets of Fire Flash Gordon and then
fat man beyond after Flash Gordon on
Friday night uh tickets if they're not
already up it's modcastlecinemas.com
that's the website they're going to be
up very very soon so if you're on the
east coast and you're like I want in on
some of this action I'm gonna run
through it again
New York City March 4th 11 p.m Cinema
Village wrong reasons with Josh Roush
Man tickets are like five bucks for
heaven's sakes go support indie film
please especially if like you're in New
York you go to one of them damn phone
schools see how a damn film is made for
heaven's sakes uh then March 5th uh fat
man beyond series at uh this podcast
Cinemas and we're showing mask of the
Phantasm then you got a few days off to
work so you can earn enough money to
come back for the Ides of Mark man which
is uh March 15 16 17th and then fat man
beyond on 17th as well that night and
then Mark's going to be at uh Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash on Saturday
from 12 till 3 or whatever uh signing
Adora signing other books he's worked on
signing your dick if you pull it out and
stretch it long enough he's that guy
[__] yeah if you've got a Sharpie I'll
sign it
um what else going on we got I know I
got uh Clerks
um open all night is coming up on the
10th but I believe that's all sold out
at this point then we have a premiere
for a movie that first Shelley Duvall
move in a long time called Forest uh
there's a show of uh there's a movie
coming up this week directed by Tommy
avaloni at smartcastle called I love you
you hate me it's a Barney documentary
wow yeah it's pretty hot man so we're
gonna be showing that if you're in indie
film
come on down kids to smog Castle Cinemas
ask for
for Kev and they'll be like he lives
upstairs uh
come see the flicks with us uh and I
think that's all we have to promote am I
right JC or did I forget
something uh I give away a secret
identity [__] sorry I think that's
everything
that's everything kids there it is man
so many opportunities to see movies uh
on the East Coast man uh wrong reasons
at Cinema Village on Sunday the 4th at
11 o'clock everything that's happening
at smodcast Castle Cinemas including
mask of the Phantasm on the fifth The
Ides of Mark on the 15th 16th and 17th
uh and then I'm back in Los Angeles on
March 18th for another uh
um Hollywood Babylon which we just did
the other night for my heart attack
aversary show so I'm gonna be
this is me going back and forth across
the country
you're gonna be [__] George Clooney
and up in the air just getting that
million mile or bonus where they just
welcome to your private Suite sir I have
always wanted to be marked I always
wanted to be uh [__] Clooney in uh up
and up in the air you know really I've
always wanted to be Clooney in in uh
out of sight no that's good Clooney
that's such a good Clooney
um but up there are really good too
Jason reitman's supposed to come to the
theater uh and show a flick so maybe
he'll show that he eventually comes
because that was his flick uh okay
enough about movies you can come see
let's talk about movies that you didn't
go see
uh all I've seen I've been preoccupied
so I have not believe it or not I have
not seen quantumania I wanted to but I
was at a place so I'm gonna be going to
see it probably tomorrow and it sounds
like I'm gonna be there by myself uh
this movie opened very big over 100
million greatest of the three Ant-Man
openings indeed first hundred million
plus grocer of 2023 if what I remember
correctly is true
uh and then it had the dubious
distinction of being the highest
drop in a second week for a Marvel movie
in history for a while it was number two
I think it's now number one they dropped
by 69 or something like that cocaine
bear almost beat it cocaine bear
directed by Elizabeth Banks of Zach and
Mary and Charlie's Angels Fame and you
know the movie where the girls sing a
lot Pitch Perfect as well
um everyone I know saw cocaine bear like
dug it like really dug it I mean it it
seems to be exactly what they promised
it would be and then you can it's hard
to go wrong delivering what you you said
you deliver
in a world where cocaine Bears earning
money moose jaws has a future my friend
yeah
[Music]
um but anyway we didn't see either of
those movies and I still didn't see
Ant-Man and the WASP colon quantumania
but one of us did one of us saw it and
was so outraged he shaved off all of his
facial hair yes my beard is in the
quantum realm
uh okay what
now let's let's just throw out spoilers
and [__]
um but it feels like anyone who wanted
to go has gone around yeah yeah
like it and it's made you know like
again Marvel is not crying poverty it's
already made
363.2 million dollars worldwide what a
failure it's I mean give me that kind of
failure I was out there touring [__]
clerks three for four months we didn't
come close to that so I want some of
that I want to be a Marvel loser [__] I
mean it's it's it's a good nice work if
you can get it
um listen it is uh I said I went to the
Chinese on on opening night you know got
my [__] take one with a Chinese six
the big one like the [__] being the
one the one where my handprints and
Footprints are right outside indeed I
went out I went and just [__] rubbed
my ass on Kevin Smith's hands in the
forecourt why didn't you just rub your
hands and Kevin Smith's hands why'd you
have to pull your ass out because
that's the love I have for a reason
so you went in and you were like yeah
[__] you're Homer Simpson holding the
mid-season flag you were like couldn't
wait well it's it's the kickoff of phase
five right like this is the beginning of
the Kang Dynasty this is we're being
introduced to the big bad for the next
you know however many Marvel movies
um I'm a fan of Jonathan Mages I think
he's a fantastic actor and so like and
and I love I love the first Ant-Man
quite a bit you know like because it's
the stakes are small it's a guy trying
to get his his daughter to spend some
time with him he's got to do a heist
that's what he does he's a [__] he's
a he's a second story man that's his
gift and so by the time you get to
Ant-Man 3
he's not a thief anymore he's not being
asked to steal anything it's still a
little bit about a father who's at a
loss with his daughter who again the
blip happened and so he spent five years
away from from Cassie Lang and so he's
returned and you know once it gets him
that time back and in the interim his
daughter has gotten a little rebellious
and she finds herself in jail because
she's you know teenager she's the
standard bag of teenage ticks that you
you give a kid in a movie like this and
but she's she's brilliant but stupid in
the same way that Tony Stark because it
gives me stupid and that she builds a
machine that nobody has to build that
can send a signal to the quantum realm
and that somehow also sucks them into it
and by them I mean everybody
I mean her her dad hope Van Dyne Hank
Van Dyne and Janet Van Dyne everybody's
back into the [__] tubes Hank Pym
Hank Pym my bad Hank and Van Dyne yeah
anywho
um and so then they're down in the
quantum realm where everything is small
and so all right sure what's the I I've
never understood what the beginning of
the quantum room was
and of course not to spoil too much
that's already in the trailers but Tang
is also down in the quantum Realm
Kang who uh had been exiled by the other
kings because apparently he's the worst
Kang
um has been trying to escape the quantum
realm and then go back to I guess the
big boy pants part of the the Galaxy
um but when Janet was there with him for
20 years that's what she was doing while
she was lost in the quantum Realm
wait what was she doing him well
um the movie would like you to believe
that she was just kind of friends with
him
not at all [__] Jonathan Mages for 20
years but instead [__] Bill Murray
for 20 years
um
at least on and off for those 20 years
um but you know they he had a machine
that could let them escape the quantum
realm and she was helping him build it
and helping him um repair it until she
had a vision that showed exactly who he
was and so she scuttled the power source
of this machine and and then was willing
to live down there in prison as long as
he never escaped and then she comes back
um because Ant-Man 2.
um
it's just a mess really kind of the
whole movie
um
some of it because they split the
characters off they split
um they split Scott and Cassie off from
the other three
um and so Scott and Cassie are just kind
of like banging around the quantum realm
running into the people who live there
deciding to get involved in rebellions
against Kang who seems to be a despot of
small Origins
um and is is oppressing the people and
Cassie wants to be a freedom fighter and
and Scott doesn't because he just wants
to save his daughter and it's a bunch of
who cares there's wasp in it at all
um wasp is kind of in it
um but she's part of the other crew
which is Hank and hope and Janet who
knows exactly what's going on she's
deathly afraid to run into Kang again
and for a minute it's an interesting
movie because it's oh hey remember when
it's a prison movie right remember when
you were in jail for 20 years and you've
never told us what happened to you in
jail now we have to go back to your jail
and so now it's you know a woman has
been keeping secrets being forced to
confront them with the people she was
keeping secrets from
um and so like that's sure we could do
that that's not bad has nothing to do
with Ant-Man at all like there's nothing
to do with Scott Lang but it's entirely
to do with Janet and hope and heck
um and then you meet Kang who's like
which Brian Hall and chat has called
kiss kiss
I likes it a lot
excuse me Kang and how badass is he I
mean he's he's pretty like he's sinewy
right he's seductive like you get what
at the Valley's Janet it's on him he's a
trickster
um and then when he reveals the the
truth of him which is like I'm a
conqueror that's what I do
um and that's right everybody the rest
of the can continue them
um buried me here exiled me here because
they don't want me to be who I am but I
oh hey
but I've got to get out and so the last
half of the movie is about how you know
how do we how do we we're supposed to
take Kang's magic
um spaceship that'll let him escape from
the quantum realm and so he captures
Cassie and forces Scott to steal it
except Scott it's not a thing to steal
it's the thing you got to repair and
it's
and there's a Modoc
there's a modak I'm acting surprised as
if I didn't know that um right there's a
Modoc and it's Darren yeah it's from the
villain from the first Ant-Man right the
guy Corey stole yeah
um which like it's a big swing like I
give him all the credit in the world for
the big swing and Modoc
um but like
it doesn't go anywhere really like it
doesn't
it it's not anybody's Story the movie is
not anybody's story even ant-man's
because his name's in the title it's
barely immature like there's the one bit
in the trailer there's two bits in the
trailers that uh that never actually
function as as story that are actually
fascinating one of them was
Scott would you like to get the time
with your daughter back I can give that
to you
and you're like oh all right so if this
is going to be a movie about Kang
offering Scott Lang the chance to have
those five years that he missed with his
kid back
that's a good hook that's a good way to
morally compromise your hero
they never do that I feel like that's a
line that was in the trailer that never
made the movie and then the other one is
you know it's like oh Scott Lang and man
haven't I killed you before that's not
in the movie it's in the movie but it
doesn't do anything like there's there's
never a real sense that there's any
connection between your villain and your
hero because there isn't like Scots
never met that dude before that dude
doesn't give a [__] about Scott Lang
like there's nothing happening between
them so and it's it's a bad guy who's
not bad to anybody except the be
trobbing peoples of the quantum realm
who we don't care about because who
cares about
so it's just I don't know who the
movie's about I'm not sure who the movie
is for other than to help introduce
who's going to be the big bad guy who's
probably in the wrong movie because it's
not you know it's a Multiverse it's the
variance it's all that [__] and Ant-Man
has nothing to do with multiverses there
was two other movies that just came out
the world about multiverses where you
probably could have put a Kang in it and
had it make some sense you know there's
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness which has its own rules of
multiverses and then there's no way home
the Spider-Man movie which has a
completely different role of multiverses
and then there's this one which has it's
yet another rule of multiverses that the
audience is somehow supposed to get a
sense of and yet they don't know
amongst themselves how to make these
things reconcile with each other
it's um
it's just a weird movie because
it's the first one of these that felt
you know driven by
a a
desire to set something up for movies
coming after this
you know like it's it's it's the first
one that feels that Craven about it I
mean of course they've all been building
planks in the ship to lead you from
phase to phase to face to face you know
the first three phases were leading you
towards
uh you know Thanos
but Thanos was a character who you could
kind of wrap your hands around you knew
what he wanted I know what Kang wants
and the fact that every Kang you meet is
a different Kang that you can dispatch
or kill and then there's more kangs to
replace them I don't know what the next
cat wants so why did I waste time with
this gang if he's spoiler I'm not going
to survive the movie
but
in case you didn't know there's a
there's a credit sequence where you meet
like a bowl of Kings each one crazier
than the next
what are they my bad guy
wow
I get it I feel like uh
I feel like
um I'm definitely still going to see the
movie but um
I don't know my bar is much lower than
most people's
so I might enjoy it yeah I mean like I
went with people who were like hey you
know what that wasn't like the worst
move I've ever seen parts of that are
kind of fun but it's very much you know
Sounder Fury signifying nothing
and this is the kickoff of phase five
yeah
yeah you know and I just think like
Ant-Man is a character
his story is kind of done
you know what more is there to say about
Scotland not very much honestly you know
so whereas I'm here for Guardians 3
because it seems like James Gunn very
much has the final story for his
Guardians for his last Marvel movie you
know he knows how he wants to send them
off be it Blaze of Glory or not
um but Scott just it feels like a
placeholder like it could have been that
could have been a Shang Chi movie you
know easily because he's got apparently
his [__] gauntlets his the ten rings
are from the quantum Realm so if you
told me that like okay so the ten Rings
might be the way that Kat wants to get
out of the quantum realm and so he's got
to pull [__] Zhang chi in so that he
can use his rings to escape
got it done
but
Scott Lang
he's just a guy
and if you're not going to make the
movie about him being just a guy and
he's not even in most of the movie
it's
a Litany of odd choices that I just
didn't understand as they were
unspooling before me
but did
um
spoilers
does I was I saw a few articles before
the movie came out that talked about
like that hinted at Ant-Man
dying
yeah no he doesn't do that
no there's there's 100 a moment where he
could
and it actually was kind of cool that
you thought that he might I think they
I think they
I think they re-shot
I mean because a lot of people online
talking about how like they reshot the
ending I don't know yeah because there's
and the lines of the trailer it's a
great one where it's like I don't have
to win
you know we just both have to lose
you know and then to give Scott Lang a
real kind of tragic here's me showing
what a normal guy can be as a hero I'm
going to sacrifice myself to save
everybody
except I don't do that because I guess
maybe it tested poorly maybe they just
didn't want it to be a downer so instead
like oh yeah no everything's fine
everybody gets to go home
chat is on fire with a series of Kang
references uh Russell cook put up one of
my favorites kangs of New York
nice nice
uh his kid Cassie I guess should being
set up for Young Avengers or whatever
yeah
like it's
you know
a thing feels like it's a setup for the
next thing
you know I mean and the Young Avengers
sort of
chess pieces are definitely being put
into place
you know
in addition to and if they do what they
did with iron lad in the comic books
it's a phenomenal fantastic way to to to
to see that story
um and I'm not gonna spoil that because
that would just be the dickish the
dickest of Dick moves on but it's pretty
cool
um
so yeah man I don't I just don't know I
just don't know
um I've seen you know selling I was
telling Batman before we rolled but I've
seen every Marvel movie with the
exception perhaps of Black Widow
um more than once
um but I don't think this is one I'll
ever really revisit
um
because I think I've I've gotten
everything there is to get out of it you
know including like and William Jackson
Harper who I loved to death who was
cheating on a good place
um who was always my pick for Reed
Richards
um is in the MCU but kind of completely
wasted as a guy who can just kind of
like read and tell if you're lying or
not
um I'm Anne Dave this mulchin is back in
an Ant-Man movie even though his
character
um I'm pretty sure it did did he die in
that man too or not they didn't I don't
think they died but I think they they uh
well they didn't bring and Michael my
opinion like a penny didn't come back I
don't think T.I came back but um but
yeah just mulching this back as a as a
alien named veb
um who's actually very funny like
there's there's some funny stuff in the
margins because that Peyton Reed knows
how to direct comedy and you know
sometimes there's a there's a really
good reaction shot of Paul Rudd who
spends most of the movie running away
from stuff until it gets big and starts
running towards stuff
one poster
that'll sell it
um so yeah I uh I look forward to to
hearing your thoughts after you see it
uh I will definitely be seeing it and
I'll definitely talk about it uh on the
next episode
um but that is uh you know it's I'm not
gonna say like how disappointing to hear
because
it's everywhere like it's very rarely do
you see somebody standing up for this
this movie
um
but you know [__]
I I ain't Mr Marvel yet I'm not about to
start with this
uh no no I mean but but I think like we
we are the ones they always had
right and what that what they did for so
long so well was turn everybody into us
like you can't miss one of these you got
to see everyone whether whether you
think you're gonna care or not like
until end game like they had everyone
but I don't know if they do anymore
clearly looking at the box office
grosses for this they don't
um I saw an article where they were
trying to like
um
yes there have been so many man uh
Moonrise Kingdom
Wu-Tang oh nice
um yeah the chat's on fire
um
I um
I you know the Articles I've seen talked
about like the box office
number one it's it open higher than any
of the other ant-mans and it opened you
know three seven figures or whatever how
many figures open to over 100 million
bucks which it would have been unheard
of
for an Ant-Man movie
um so and as Mark pointed out earlier
movies going to make like it's right now
up to 364 million it'll probably top off
between five six hundred million on a
budget of 200 million so you know
they're not hurting Marvel's certainly
still doing better than most at the box
office but you're right for a while they
had everybody like not just the people
who are like I'm seeing this no matter
what they had people who were like what
is what is what's an Iron Man well I
don't care I love Iran man
um it's uh I wonder what happens from
here though I mean we know the next
Marvel movie is Guardians 3 and there's
no way that James Gunn drops the ball
especially with the third outing and the
final outing and stuff
um so I'm sure they can write their ship
if it was indeed at all
knocked off course
um yeah I mean I think that that it does
just kind of show that
even though they always say it's easier
to destroy it than it is to create
creating in this regard was the
quote-unquote easy part building the MCU
building towards end game
like yeah we have a trajectory we have a
path we know where we're going we know
what the bad guy is we know how to build
to that we know how to give everybody
their mom in the Sun and then bring it
all home
sustaining is the harder part like how
to keep going after that how to keep you
know just all right we gotta we gotta
figure out who the new version of these
heroes are who who are we going to care
about who is an audience going to come
and root for because we don't have Downy
anymore we don't have Evans anymore Thor
has been in for these who knows him
anymore we're going to get of him Chris
Pratt's about to go you know into the
sunset with guardians 3 like who are our
rallying characters that an audience is
gonna get a lean on and I don't know who
they are and I don't know who their bad
guy is aside from you know it's going to
be Kang but which version of Kang also
like in terms of that you know everyone
naturally everyone wants to compare Kang
and Thanos but correct me if I'm wrong
but like Thanos didn't have his own full
movie until Infinity War right yeah I
mean he's he just popped up in a scene
here a you know [__] post-credits
scene there but like this is a movie
that sounds like they're based on what
you said they take their bad guy who's
meant to be the bad guy going forward
and meant to be the new Thanos
and
you know I know we met him in Loki or a
version of him he remains but and I know
and it sounds like if if you're about
the post-credit sequence if there are
multiple kangs then obviously they can
afford to kill them off willy-nilly but
I don't you know I don't obviously I
ain't telling the [__] MCU what to do
but I just don't know that I would
if if we're building toward a Thanos
like you know appearance for the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars I just don't
know that I would have
tipped my hand so soon like I play
little pieces of them as opposed to
you know hey man here's a whole ass Kang
movie especially when they had Modoc up
in this [__]
yeah yeah I mean I don't know maybe it's
one of those like if you have a Ferrari
you kind of want to drive it and if you
have Jonathan Majors you want to give
him [__] to do
um and you just want to let him run
because he's so [__] magnetic he's so
talented but like
has come up with the woman Kang
I'm down to see Jonathan Majors as the
woman gang Jed Berry came up with Catch
Me If You Can
Dynamite some [__] Snakes on a Kang
they're having a good ass time how was
uh Modoc in terms of I know who it is
but
it's just it's a weird it's such a weird
choice that like the minute he shows up
you're like are they [__] they're
doing Modoc okay they're doing modak but
then
they kind of give modak a story and like
uh like a little Redemption Arc
kind of like the last half of the movie
becomes very Thor Ragnarok
it becomes very like all right we're
staging a rebellion against the big evil
despot who's keeping all of us down and
here of all the little people that Scott
and Cassie have met are all gonna march
on the big capital and we're having a
revolution
all of that and then Modoc goes from
being Kang's like faithful henchmen to
an agent of the Revolution like he's got
a change of heart because Cassie
forgives him
oh because he tried to kill her as a
little girl yeah
yep
so that happened
oh yeah you know I gotta tell you man
like it does not Dull my interest I'm
yeah I I can sometimes be the same way
like it's not like I don't care how bad
you tell me cats is I'm gonna go see me
some [__] cats
I have to see it now
yeah I want to see the CGI butthole yes
okay give me the [__] cut
um wow man well there it is uh Mark's
thoughts on
Kang the movie
um AKA and yeah Quantum me
um
I guess for those wondering uh Mark of
course is in the middle of a Merchant
Ivory movie that's what that window
behind him is I believe it's the remains
of the day you're in or uh you know it
could be it could be Room with a View
yeah
your background my background is
uh it's one of the load screens for The
Last of Us video game
oh if uh if you've never played The Last
of Us or watch the TV show
um windows are a big theme in that game
um you know Windows leading to new
worlds Windows leading to opportunity
Windows signifying regret
um 95 Windows 95 Windows yeah Windows of
the world
um and in episode three of of The Last
of Us
um the great Frank and Bill episode
featuring Marie Bartlett and Nick
Offerman
um the very last shot is of a window
um
much like this and it's very sad
how is uh The Last of Us you've been
watching now you were a big fan of the
video game I'm a massive fan of the
video games
um and I have been watching it's it's an
interesting process because I know where
it's going
um but and I'm always curious to see the
detours that they take on the way to
getting where it's going
um some of them are great some are
fantastic
um some of them like this most recent
episode which is based entirely on
a chapter of the downloadable content
um called Left Behind which is this just
sort of lovely little teenage romance
um between Ellie and this other girl
named Riley we're in the middle of you
know [__] bombed out Boston they
discover a shopping mall
um and they turn all the lights on and
then it becomes this weird amusement
park of just these two kids like kind of
playing in the the the the debris of a
world that's long since gone by
I'm like hey there's a carousel in the
middle of it and hey there's a toy store
and hey there's a record shop and hey
there's
um
and I think that that the issue that I'm
having with the the show if if it can
even be called an issue is that in the
game you had 20 25 hours to spend with
your main characters and to watch them
get closer together and to watch them go
from from sort of enemies barely aligned
enemies to really father and daughter
um the show has only got nine hours to
do that
and it's by compressing that time it's
putting a lot more import on them sort
of forcing these two characters together
so given that that's the brief the time
they spend not building that
relationship
um is is curious to me and so like yeah
I want to see Joel and Ellie like Pedro
Pascal and Bell Ramsey are fantastic I
want to see them learn to love each
other
um and the more we spend apart from them
the more I'm less interested in it
um
because we do we're giving all this love
to other characters that are not them
um so I just kind of
um yeah I'm just that decision is
interesting to me I'm not saying it's a
wrong one I'm not saying it's a Right
One issues it's interesting
uh Matthew West and chat came up with
Austin Zager that's uh
Harley's boyfriend who was also in clerk
three he was in scary stories telling
the dark whatever Guillermo's produced
movie was Matthew West said Austin's age
or is block Kang Coltrane I mean his
name was blockchain Coltrane and clerks
three it's a deep Cuts joke but if you
like clerks three like I do
joke was a goddamn winner yeah I
appreciate it Mitch the man said
Kangaroo Jack Black Kingsman hi Doug
that's good L.A Kang Financial
Mr King
Beverly Hills Kang catch me if you can
I'm here for all the Kang man
someone put Meg Kang
congratulations
heavy come on that's deep Cuts wonderful
man wow
wow um okay
what uh what else can we talk about
um we have a little bit of news it's
been it's been a relatively dry news
span and I I suppose given the uh the
fact that we are on the precipice of
Mandalorian season three we can always
invite that is tonight at midnight are
you [__] me March one it goes live
look before we go into that let's talk
about I know we haven't done it on this
show yet
um holy [__] that Flash trailer
yeah
I've watched that Flash trailer No Lie
easily 200 times already it is [__]
magic
um I uh
I I cannot wait I and Mark I don't have
to wait because as I've discussed on uh
Hollywood Babylon last weekend with
Ralph
uh as a owner of a movie theater
that makes me a member of NATO
that's right National Association of
theater owners kids nothing to do with
the nuclear club and when you're a NATO
member you could go to what used to be
called show west but is now called
cinemacon and that's the first place
they're gonna show the [__] Flash
movie in April now as Kevin Smith
filmmaker
filmmaker I would never be allowed into
this [__] thing unless I had
something I was presenting at cinemacon
but as Kevin Smith theater owner they
cannot keep me out man
so I'm gonna be in Vegas for cinemacon
this little black duck right here
I'm gonna be dappy for seeing me some
[__] flash way early man I'm gonna
come back to this show spoil the [__]
out of it outstanding
um walrus onion and chat wants us to to
sneak in like little rascal style where
we get a giant Overcoat
get a couple of us in it yeah I've lost
some weight and [__] you're shaved so
I'll be the body you beat a [__] baby
face
they're like look at this youngster
movie theater
um that [__] trailer has two of my
favorite Batman in the world in it
um it's got you know [__] a story
that looks
you know I'm not certainly not gonna say
it's better than [__] uh uh
Flashpoint and [__] but they took
elements of Flashpoint they took
elements of [__] Frank Miller's Dark
Knight strikes again man like in terms
of the
hidden Kryptonian you know who's all
emaciated until the [__] Sun hits and
[__] like that
um and best of all is that's our Batman
[__] that's Michael Keaton Batman the
only thing cooler than that would have
been Adam West Batman but you know we
lost Adam West so I can't [__] wait
man he comes off so come on how I mean I
know it happened weeks ago and [__] but
how [__] awesome was him going yeah
I'm Batman like oh my God just take my
[__] money take all of it Warner
Brothers I didn't even I was so happy
with Warner Brothers I didn't give a
[__] when they were like you can't show
Batman Returns I was like anything you
say both of them Wonder Brothers man I
can't wait um the guy who directed as a
guy that did it yeah
let me tell you something this movie
looks [__] astounding remember we
would talk about like why aren't they
canceling this movie
now we know they were like we got gold
man this movie's giving life left and
right
so I'm there
I'm I can't wait I I can't wait so much
so that I'm going to Vegas to see the
movie early
uh when that happens in April uh we'll
I'll be reporting back from Cinema con
tell you what else I see because I'm
sure I'll see some Marvel previews there
as well I can't wait man I'm they're
gonna be people on stage who I know from
the business who are going to be like so
anyway my
Kevin and I'm going to be in the
audience holding up my cinemacon flag
like Homer
I just I very much want you to have like
a fat man beyond microphone with a
little [__] Flag around it little
head on it reporting live from Cinema
con Kevin Smith and Batman Beyond how
awesome is this movie
um yeah man that's that's my uh
has given me life that [__] Michael
Keaton
Batman I hear I'm I'm I suspect
calling it now he don't make it through
this movie
um but that would be I wouldn't even be
sad about that if they were like this is
Batman's last [__] run oh
oh all of that [__] trailer is just
so [__] good do you think I've seen a
lot of people online talking about the
younger Barry and how he's wearing like
a yellow hoodie that's very reminiscent
of eobard Thon
do you think
that's a thing or is it just
I mean to a certain degree I hope not
because like don't
don't encrust this with so much lore
that makes it hard for your average
[__] normally to know what the hell
is going on like it's kind of like it's
such a simple setup like this is the
universe in which my mom doesn't die
and I'm going to [__] protect it but
as a result I've ruined the space-time
Continuum and here's [__] Zod again
and coming to prey on an earth it's
fantastic was that too like who knew
that I'd miss Zod so much that when they
dropped him in the trailer and he's like
we've been waiting for you I was like oh
my God like Michael Sheridan's back it
looks so [__] dope I just love that
Michael Shannon is just like you know
what yeah I'll come back and do this
again you know why I'm sure they were
like
and he was like more
he's like I need more they didn't pay me
on George and Tammy more
good for him man [__] he's one of our
greatest actors and [__] I when I
watched that trailer that made me go
back and re-watch Man of Steel and [__]
man did I have a good time watching that
so much so that I then went forward and
watched Batman v Superman I had a good
ass time doing that as well
um when I saw that [__] trailer drop
man I texted Zach and I was just like
snyderverse lives bro like there's
[__] Zod there's the world engine
there's your flash there's bat Fleck
it's nuts man I can't wait for this
[__] movie I cannot [__] wait I
know I saw their announcement of like
you know things to come like Gods and
Monsters chapter one whatever all that
stuff looks wonderful but I know this
movie was like conceived and [__]
directed long before they decided to
reboot the DC Universe and stuff and
just now call it the DCU which makes
more sense than GCU or whatever they
were calling it but I I don't know man
this thing looks [__] phenomenal I
saw somebody in chat and be like uh it's
a no way home ripoff good because no way
home rocked and if they're gonna rip off
anything [__] rip that off man if you
give me the DC Universe DCU you version
of [__] no way home
I'm there can't wait man flash ring in
full effect
word is that bat Fleck gives him the
flash ring oh
oh that Fleck in a blue [__] variant
suit
and that [__] in the other Super Bowl
teaser but they showed the [__] room
full of Batman outfits and [__]
I I honestly feel like this movie was
[__] made just for me it's like
they're like he almost died from a heart
attack five years ago let's make a movie
that will [__] finally kill him and
because this movie was so good I think I
just want to see it and then like
pass on and [__] my God it looks [__]
phenomenal
not wait
cannot [__] wait and anybody that's
like ill you're a shill how can I shell
for a movie I haven't seen yet that
trailer just made me so [__] excited
man there's a reason I've watched it
hundreds of [__] times it's like it
delivers that trailer is wonderful and
if the movie is like as good as the
trailer and I hope it's better come on
that one moment was like Batman what do
we do try not to die and then [__]
like moves his hand and there's [__]
Supergirl oh
that's jizz
no you're not playing cards in a black
jacket no I ain't dealing
they're [__] giving out Aces [__] man
that looks good
um all right
enough about that yeah
um a little bit of news we can kind of
Blaze through
um
one of the things that Kim was announced
most recently
um by uh David zasloff and the Warner
Brothers Discovery machine is that we're
getting more Lord of the Rings movies
yeah I saw that I have they haven't they
run out a book yet I mean
I
I mean Peter Jackson's movies all 12
hours of them already won 17 Oscars
um back between 2001 and 2004. that's a
big memory
of these movies happening not too long
ago I remember watching the Academy
Awards where we won quite a few trophies
I'm sure and then after that he made
three more movies based on the Hobbit
um and now they're apparently like
they're looking to bring the world of Jr
token back to the screen in new and
exciting ways
um that the the the the people who own
the rights and Warner Brothers
understand how cherish these works are
and the serious plan is to honor the
past look to the Future and adhere to
the strongest level of quality and
production values
um
Bamford and apparently somebody thinks
that there's a there's a lot of Dr
tolkien's universe that remains largely
unexplored on film yeah that just sounds
like Amazon shade to me is what that
sounds like
[__] series they made a show
that was
extremely mediocreally received
is that right the most expensive
television show ever and people were
like
that was on that was on the internet
so I think this is Warner Brothers being
like hey we can make movies that people
might get excited about
I mean you know what they should do
just lord of the Kings
just
Synergy I see what you do there bring it
all together yeah I don't I don't it it
just feels like another instance and
I've been feeling this recently
of there are no new things anymore you
know nobody's trying to launch a new
franchise and he's trying to I mean John
Wick is the most recent one that I can
think that actually kind of worked where
we made a movie
oh shitty dumb
yeah really hard to chew not doing its
job gum no there's I better to be fair
is there an expiration date expires
October 2021 Mark so I guess perhaps
shouldn't be [__] with that gum in
the first place if I start vomiting all
over the screen it's because I ate very
old gum kids I got classic Big League
Chew man from
1978. I think it [__] took my [__]
jaw and
it's back what is it I believe I could
be wrong I could be getting this wrong
but Todd field from tar writer director
apparently
invented Big League Chew
when he was a bat boy for a minor league
baseball team and he and one other guy
apparently invented Big League Chew when
he was a kid
is he [__] Super Rich no I because he
was a kid I think the other guy
like it was all that other guy made all
the money and like kept the company
I remember reading that around the you
know part of the the tar Oscar [__]
Round Table press Siege or whatever it's
like yeah I made I made a big league too
it's like I ate a lot of Big League Chew
could you imagine like could you imagine
like you're a director you're the
director of little children
perhaps one of the greatest American
films made in the last 20 years
and you also invented Big League Chew
like it ain't right I got clerks through
clerks three so when it comes to no new
ideas
but I ain't got [__] like oh by the
way I also invented [__] Reese's
peanut butter cups or you know [__]
the Easter egg or [__] nothing like
yeah my middle name is Cadbury sir yeah
hey man you like the eggs with the fake
cream and [__]
me and a buddy when we were 12 came up
with that in a few jizz and all this
candy sold them
that's like nobody should have two
things in this world
I feel like he's got two things I
haven't seen tar did you see tar I have
not yet either I've I haven't seen many
of the oscar-nominated films
um but the one that I did see that
I would love to win is everything
everywhere all at once but she seems to
be doing great like bag Awards they
clean the [__] up
it's uh it's so good it's I mean I saw
it in February when it first came out
and was just blown the [__] away
[Music]
um [__] man all right so more Lord of
the Rings is coming you can't [__]
stop it Hobbit's coming out Warner
Brothers ass
um what is it they they own that right
they made a deal with the license the
company that controls the license
um and new line Cinema given that they
had made the original Lord of the Rings
movies with Peter Jackson I guess had
[__] pole position and zazzloff was
like spend all the money if we can get
more of these movies let's get more of
these movies you know there's also talk
that he's trying to convince you know
whomever I suppose that's JK Rowling
um to make more Harry Potter movies I
was just gonna say like [__] in a
world where they're like oh let's do
Lord of the Rings again why aren't they
[__] like all right let's start Harry
Potter from scratch with a whole new
cast and stuff yeah I mean I think they
they want to just do more I think
they're just like hey these kids these
kids are not grown up you wrote a
version of these characters that are now
older the Harry Potter and the curse of
child let's just adapt that let's just
break that into two or three movies and
let's just go which to be fair I never
saw that play but like look you want to
make a bunch of [__] money with the
Harry Potter World bring back to kids
that everyone grew up watching and now
they're adults and [__] like that they
could make out
it's [__] yeah we could see some ass
shots in the shower you know because
it's a kids thing but still you know
those kids are all grown up they could
go like Harry goes to see his
cardiologist like I did today [__] uh
Ron Weasley is uh you know
dealing with male pattern baldness
oh the beauty of middle age and [__] wow
expecto colonoscopy
I'd take that man you know I still
haven't had a [__] uh I know I'm I'm
the overdue mine as well yeah I guess I
should do that soon what is it called
again colonoscopy colonoscopy yeah I
haven't done that yet I got a clean bill
of health in my heart
but I should have my ass checked out
um
let that be a lesson kids get your ass
checked
who hasn't gotten his ass checked out
you want to hang out with a bunch of
geezers talking about the procedures
they should have welcome
um I look I understand that Warner
Brothers is a massive [__] movie
company and [__] like that hold on I'm
gonna take a hit of my lavender
oh so calming Mark so common in a world
where I don't smoke weed anymore this is
replaced weed now just every once in a
while I'm like
sniff it give me them essential oils
sniff it back
um I I can understand why that company
is like yeah make more of the [__] that
made money and whatnot but I'm one of
them of an old school I'm not saying
they shouldn't do things they can do
whatever the [__] they want but you know
in my I was the guy that when they
announced Disney bought [__] the Star
Wars franchise I was like why would you
buy a dead franchise
never realizing that they were like it
ain't gonna be dead anymore get the [__]
up Skywalk again [__] so I guess
in a world where you can [__]
continue the Star Wars saga I guess you
continue the Lord of the Rings you can
continue Harry Potter anything that
that's gonna turn a [__] dime I guess
but you're right it's seems few and far
and again not criticism because I made
clerks three but it seems few and far
between where people are like let's try
a brand new [__] thing like no it's
all about Nostalgia books where it's
like the only way to get them to come
out to out to the theater is to give
them their childhood back or not even
their childhood some [__] that happened
two years ago in some cases
but I mean I just remember like
the [__] this was the summer of 99
when you had like The Sixth Sense and
the Matrix uh by the way Dogma as well
and Fight Club
you know like it was it was this
glorious moment where it was just the
new and Studios were behind it and just
rolling the Dyson and in most cases
making [__] money and making movies
that people remember and none of it's
based on IP really except for Fight Club
but it was a book that I'm not sure how
many people actually read you know and
and so then you get to have lots of
[__] matrixes maybe we didn't need
lots of matrixes I don't know but you
got to build a new thing and you got to
build the thing that people are now
nostalgic for and if you're not gonna
try the new thing then just continuing
to reheat the old stuff it's just it's
diminishing returns after a while
you know and I don't know it's a quick
fix I get it like Alex Lee points out on
chat that 65 is a new IP coming out the
movie with uh right Adam Driver [__]
shooting dinosaurs with lasers holy [__]
that sounds like an idea like I would
have come up with when I was smoking
like
Adam Driver
lasers dinosaurs go which actor looks
most like a crow magnet
Adam Driver is that how you see one of
our greatest actors
whenever I see him I don't think of I
don't think that at all I think is just
like God damn that guy's good I also
rewatched uh the uh
uh
um what do they call them they're not
the prequels but the the the sequels the
gas
um JJ's two and Ryan Ryan's uh middle
one and third Trilogy Adam drivers is so
[__] amazingly good
and uh
in uh what was the second one Last Jedi
last yes that's right with Marco and
like and I will not be the last Jedi
Adam Driver when they meet when [__]
kylo Ren and Luke Skywalker meet on you
know the [__] salt planet and [__]
and uh he's like I'm sorry Ben and
[__] Adam driver's like I'm sure you
are
it's [__] good
um but yeah man 65 looks amazing yeah I
mean I'm always here for a good high
concept like Enemy Mine type [__] where
it's like what are we doing oh Tyler roo
as in chat says stop making sense
strong come on man that's so damn good
uh Lord monk says The Last of Us is new
IP is it
I mean based on the game sure but I mean
it existed before so it's not new IP
it's IP I mean I don't I don't
particularly mind like an adaptation of
a book per se because we've been doing
that since the beginning of time
but like how many times can you go back
to the same well
Evan Fowler and chat brought up the line
from Last Jedi I want every gun we have
to fire on that man it was such a
[__] great scene man and you know
when I first saw it I was like why
couldn't he have act spoilers what
spoilers if you haven't seen the last
[__] Jedi
um I'll wait you can turn this down but
I remember when the first time I saw it
I was like look I thought it was awesome
that he was [__] not really there and
that he was force projecting himself
from across the [__] galaxies
but
it also would have been cool if he was
just there and like
but he even says in the movie he's like
wait what am I going to face down the
[__] first order with a laser sword
and [__]
um he's a good ass flick man I know
everyone loves Ryan Johnson's like uh
you know [__] what are they called
yeah the glass onions yeah but what was
the original title knives out his Knives
Out flicks and stuff and I guess he's
got Poker Face on peacocks which I like
I like dick yeah I'm I'm up to date
every Thursday they drop them and
they're Colombo's they're episodes of
Colombo is that right it's I mean the
font is the exact same font it has the
same the the premise of Columbo as
always the audience knows what happened
they just don't know how Colombo is
going to figure out how the murder
happened and that's every one of these
every one of these is a done in one you
know if there's any connective tissue
it's very very thin but it's you know
Natasha Leone is Charlie kale who can
just tell when people lie and you find
yourself in like dinner theater
communities and Texas barbecue and guys
who work at rest stops and you know
makeup [__] Wizards like the most
recent episode
has Nick Nolte
as basically Ray harryhausen
um a guy who yeah promotion artist who
just does stop-motion artist he builds
models and maquettes and he does
stop-motion stuff
and uh and and Cherry Jones is uh is is
his partner they started a an effects
company that I think it's in the in the
show it's called Alm or something like
that and it's and there's a murder and
who did it and why and just it's so
[__] smart even even when the
episodes aren't great they're just still
really enjoyable
a few people in chat have been
um
pointing out that uh blumhouse you know
while doing
what they do is also introducing new IP
yeah I mean and horror was always horror
was both of those things at once there
would be Nightmare on Elm Street six but
then there would always be [__]
leprechaun and then leprechaun six and
then the hills have eyes and The Hills
Have Eyes three like there was always
this sense of we got to put some new
[__] out there so it can be the new
series Once the old series run out of
steam
and blumhouse is like yeah we'll make
more stuff and win more stuff but then
when it hits then we'll do like
whatever the Mia goth stuff the like X
and whatever the movie before X was
which I didn't see because I don't watch
horror but even still the if we make it
for cheap enough you can put a lot of it
out some of it will work some of it
won't and we'll hit and some of it will
just be a one great movie we made once
uh someone in chat averillado Espinoza
said did I miss the Ant-Man talk yes you
did Mark has reviewed Ant-Man uh
spoilers I didn't see it so I'll review
it on a future episode when I finally
see it uh but to catch you up
uh Mark shaved I haven't completed in
five weeks
with a bunch of stuff going on at
smodcast Castle and wrong reasons
playing in uh New York City at Cinema
Village on Saturday night uh more Ides
of Mark playing uh at uh smod Castle
March 15th to March 17th and now you're
caught up yeah that's pretty much it
mask of the Phantasm March 5th it's
modcastle Cinemas you can watch it with
me man
oh look at how fast Banff Ben is getting
that [__] graphic up
yeah you don't [__] around
um
all right what else are we talking about
um one tiny other news story
um
is that there had been a show that was
in development at HBO Max based on a
Neil Gaiman comic book called Dead boy
detectives yes with Matt Wagner he did
that with Matt Wagner years ago indeed
um who created Mage and Grendel Grendel
which was going to be a Netflix show but
apparently is not going forward
um the well maybe dead boy to Texas was
taking the Netflix slot because it is
now shifting from HBO Max
over to Netflix to join Neil gaiman's
other massive show Sandman which was
previously also a Warner Brothers HBO
thing that they then let go and Netflix
picked it up is this a uh David zasslov
thing
um it's part of I think deslov's new
version or vision four how HBO Max and
DC Comics and basically everything that
Warner Brothers Homes Works which is
if we can make money selling it on the
open market we'll sell in the open
market if it's a thing that we think we
can make money by making in-house and
it'll drive subscriptions we'll do that
too
um so yeah this is this is another thing
that has been allowed to leave the barn
um and this was a this was a this was a
big deal like this show wasn't it a
berlante show as well it's a berlante
show
um and it might
I don't know what this says about
berlante and Warner Brothers if they're
letting everything berlante kind of go
out the door blending was also behind
Doom Patrol and Titans
um and he's no longer overseeing the
Green Lantern series
I don't know
[Music]
I don't know everything's so different
yeah but his his role in the new DC is
essentially non-existent
um so weird because he was the guy that
like kept DC hope alive on TV for a red
hot minute yeah I mean flash Arrow
Legends of Tomorrow Supergirl we're all
brillanty shows
and now the flash ending it's run I
think this season was the last of them
oof
oof oof exchange man things change
indeed
um and all we have left to talk about
then is what we think will happen in
Mandalorian season three
and I don't think I'm right as of
midnight we get to find out as of
midnight you know as long as you have
seen the two episodes of book of Boba
Fett that were actually Mandalorian 2.3
and 2.4
um you're caught up you're ready to
rumble
[Music]
um the uh did they drive some I saw some
of the news about an Ahsoka trailer
which I guess hasn't happened yet but
I guess there was some update on the
Ahsoka Trail there's a news item about
when the Ahsoka trailer is gonna drop
maybe Banff man knows more about that he
[__] lives and breathes Star Wars I
don't know if you know this kids but you
can go to Hollywood Los Angeles where
the motion pictures are from and on
Hollywood Boulevard they got the scum
and villainy cantina which uh is a geek
bar great place to [__] hang out get
your geek on drink liquor knock it into
fights unless those fights are like Star
Trek versus Star Wars or something like
that anyway the proprietor of that there
Cantina is a big Star Wars nut no
relation whatsoever to The Cantina uh so
maybe he knows Banff man Ahsoka trailer
um according to the internet Star Wars
celebration in April
and Star Wars celebration is not in
America this year it is in London
I mean yay for England but like
and then and I know it's like people
from England have to come over to
America when they do celebration but
like Americans most Americans don't
really want to jump on a plane and go to
England to
see the show I don't know you know what
do I [__] know about what most
Americans want but
feels like money's tight right now it
seems like a long way to go for they're
not doing like and one in Anaheim
they announced 20 they're gonna skip
2024 and 2025 will be the the one after
London
so we're not even kidding one
wasn't it I mean wasn't always like one
of the states and then one abroad and
then one back in the States and then one
abroad and the States was always like
Anaheim or Florida like the pre-disney
kind of did that and then Disney was
like
why do one every other year when we
could do one every eight minutes
so
you know shout out to Russell cooking
shot who came up with to Kang Fu Thanks
for Everything Julie Newmar
uh that is deep [__] Cuts right there
man I appreciate that impressive one of
my favorite Brian durkey said scum and
villainy cantina
oh [__] nice that's a free ad right
there man
um yeah somebody at Ben bamboo said Star
Wars is huge amongst the Brits too Kev
guessing they want to give them
something too I 100 agree and I'm happy
for the folks over in the UK but just
seems like a lot of Americans might be
like what fly to [__] England to see
some Star Wars [__] Over My Dead Body
but I don't know maybe it's sold out
already I mean it sold out really quick
I bought I'm on it and I didn't get four
day passes I got
I had to buy a single day pass for each
day
are you so you're going over to the UK
yeah because Jen got coveted during the
last celebration I had to leave early so
I was like well looks like we're going
to London that's my makeup but then I'm
then she I'm taking her on a trip
through
uh UK and Ireland
today and JC's kid is taller and older
than Mark already it's crazy
yeah just over two
just over two and I swear she looks like
she's ready to go to kindergarten man
she's talking walking I was like I I
felt I thought I fell into uh the
quantum realm
years later when she was a completely
different actress than the baby I last
saw
yeah it was pretty pretty wild she got
big quick
my camera keeps falling off
um
yeah Mando tonight we're doing so
they're having the movie premiere in
Hollywood so as soon as I'm rap the show
I'm going down to the bar to hang out
with all the people who saw the premiere
like right now what do you mean where's
the where was the premiere I think at El
Cap
um
at the El cab you could have bought
tickets for it no it's like cast crew
invite influencer thing apparently we're
not influencers uh but I know a bunch of
people who went and then they're coming
to they usually show like two or three
episodes and then
I guess people are coming to the bar
after
very cool
Disney filthy Disney lucra uh Katie
Sackhoff is gonna be in it a bunch it
seems which yeah
what a bunch
um it looks like episodes like the
trailers look like episodes of Clone
Wars which you know seems awesome
a lot of people with jet packs and
flamethrowers and
major Pascal just [__] like Jonathan
Majors everywhere
Jonathan Majors got [__] uh Creed
Three coming out right yeah Friday and
that trailer looks fantastic that was
directed by [__] Michael B Jordan
mm-hmm
if the young beautiful actors of this
generation are going to direct Mark what
hope do people like you and I
none whatsoever I was like I'm just
trying to get this done before I'm 50.
and here's [__]
like hold my beer yeah um there's a lot
of people in chat asking why I've
stopped smoking weed uh because I did it
for 15 years and now I just want to be
present uh when I started smoking weed
kids
um I had a very big wound in my heart
and uh weed was a really nice bandage
that I put on top of it and then the
wound kept getting bigger and then I put
on more bandages and then one day I
realized that I was as bandaged up as a
mummy and I couldn't see clearly and I
couldn't hear clearly and
wasn't really present anymore I was
there that's the beautiful thing about
weed is you could be there and not be
there at all it's not like booze where
people you know can tell hey can tell
you're drunk and B it probably impairs
most people if you go too far with it
wheat I could smoke an entire you know
small
state Rhode Island worth of weed and
still do my job very very well uh but
you know it was also keeping me absent
from life and you know probably aided in
making a bunch of poor decisions so
uh now I'm I'm just I'm seeing what life
is like out from from under I had a
brain mapping done uh over the course of
the last month and uh you know I was
very
lucky that like you know it hasn't
done some
irreparable damage to my brain but this
is something I [__] learned in the
process do you know that the brain is 97
fat
I didn't but now I love my brain even
more right oh my God it loves yodels and
[__] Double Dogs straight up
chocolate milk but since you know THC
could cross the blood-brain barrier once
it finds your brain it's like oh my God
and it just lives on it because you know
that's what weed does man you can take a
bag of ditch weed the worst [__] weed
in the world and if you cook it up with
some [__] you know butter it'll find
that fat molecule attach and become a
potent [__] edible and [__] so I just
wanna I wanna see what life is like with
Clarity I don't want to be numb anymore
I want to be here 52 I've been numb for
15 years my friend Malcolm and I were
talking about the other day and he's
like oh my God you almost hit your
15-year anniversary you know because the
first time I started smoking weed in
earnest
later in life because I I'd enjoyed it a
few times when I was you know in my late
teens and early 20s
uh but I only started smoking weed
regularly at age 38 you know most people
like but you've always been a stoner no
those are the characters that I created
or came up with or whatever [__]
um
you know I I didn't start smoking weed
myself until age uh 38. so
I uh you know it's been almost 15 years
we've wrapped Zach and Miri Make a Porno
uh 15 years ago this month
so you know that kind of started me
smoking weed um I spoke with Seth on the
last night of the shoot and then didn't
[__] smoke again until the following
July and then after that I started
smoking on the regular so iron down on
it man if you like weed I used to love
weed so [__] have at it kids uh but
I've been numb enough now I want to be
present and uh see what life was like
out from under all the gauze
so there you go there's an answer it's
the best answer you're gonna get and
it's true
um somebody said so weed is to blame for
that movie
that's a funnier joke if you say what
movie it is do you want me to insert a
title yogosers there you go see
gotta include a title of the movie or
else the joke
um my favorite part of chat was the
number of people
surprised about you not smoking weed and
then comparing it to the number of
people talking about Mark having a clean
shaven face
so many people there was one guy at the
beginning he was like I recognize Kev
who's the other [__] guy who's the 12
year old just pretending to be an adult
if I had to bet before the show I would
have put like 10 to 1 on you not smoking
weed but it was like
seven to six okay yeah thankfully Mark
took all the heat off me by being like
being baby smooth and freaking everybody
the [__] out that's my plan free people
to [__] out
uh lots of folks conjecturing
uh like why
somebody here was like did you get a big
money gig
and that's why you stopped smoking weed
somebody made you sign a contract yes
they gave me Quantum Mania too
they were like make sense of this Tyler
Bob but you can't smoke weed I was like
I won't you got it
um no no conspiracy theory uh some
people ask them am I still gonna sell
branded weed I'm not against weed I'm
just not smoking it myself but if I was
smoking weed by gum of course I would
smoke my own weed caviar and oil makes
chickens and snoochy booties and
Berserker
um but yeah everyone's looking for a
why why why you know I just trying to be
present trying to be mindful evil vet in
chat was like next week March starts
weed
yes and I'll shave and then we'll have
something to talk about yeah
um where to next should we do some q a
that's all the news we got we might as
well well we just answered one of the
[__] cues why the [__] are you stop
smoking weed what's your problem
um JC uh Banff man yeah I've got some
stuff
um
Laura D wanted to know
uh what drug and what animal would you
make a movie about so like cocaine bear
what's what's they announced I think
meth Gator or like Asylum that kind of
like
the trans Morphers like
spoof movie company doing meth Gator so
what would you guys the animal and the
drug
um
let me see
ambasol gopher
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
uh
Edibles moose Jaws
um I don't think you need to put a
[__] drug in front of moose Jaws to
make that work
um
see now that I stopped smoking weed I
have no funny things to say no good
ideas kids
now I'm
what does he say at the end of uh
[__] Goodfellas I'm just a schmuck
like everybody else
just a [__] schmuck
um
vodka shark
look at that that was [__] fast shark
swim in liquid vodka is a liquid
it is the tragedy of it is he's got no
hands to drink the vodka but he really
loves the [__] Factor he's just like
and so if you pour it in the ocean it
just dilutes immediately
if it's a basking shark his mouth's
always open so he's always drinking it
damn there you go he just hangs out
outside of breweries just hoping to get
a sweet bit of the runoff
uh Calo Zane says Preparation H Pig
let's see that big popper Pig
fentanyl Panda says agent double O soul
um Lord monk said I would think Kev
would have picked a walrus okay
um what removal walrus
I just I go booze more than I go drugs
so I'm like wall bang on walrus we know
we watch you get all [__] up and
[__] the bar once when you're like
give me some of that [__] what was it
Skywalker Skywalker Ranch Rose
Mark got [__] up on Rose I got [__]
up like a two o'clock at the marina
watch me go seems like a good time to
pop in and let people know that we now
serve Skywalker Pinot Noir by the glass
look at that [__] man go to scum and
villain and cantina get yourself some
Skywalker wine but those two things have
nothing to do with each other so please
don't alert me
um vodka shark and uh and whatever the
one you picked was Walter M.C said rum
Rhino nice I like it kind of nice I like
it all right question one in the books
um Jeff Ruble says vodka shark versus
swim up bar
nice let's go get that [__] on [__]
sci-fi today
I do think the Sharknado people are like
what the [__] man
like we're the ones that mix an animal
with a [__] thing
I do this for 20 [__] years you guys
Laval Angela did you miss lavalantula
one of our favorites
it's like you need to get the guys who
did Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey to
team up with cocaine bear for like blood
and honey too colon cocaine
and it's just Piglet and Pooh just
snorting
I'm there for that holy [__]
um in a world where they could kill
let's watch them do drugs and see what
happens
[Music]
and they dream of a boy that talks
directed by Oliver Stone
second question I gotta hit me some
[__] lavender for the second question
all right uh this is so realized
walrus onion wants to know using anyone
from pop culture who is on your
respective Starship Cruise
so you're gonna you're gonna you've got
a spaceship you've gotta crew it up
you can pick whoever you want who do you
take
anybody in pop culture
yep
Batman
Jesus Christ uh
let's see uh Dr zayas
you get the jam he could get us out
um Rick and or Morty
um
let's see well Rick more than Morty
my dad
because he's dead so it'd be nice to see
him on his [__] Intergalactic cruise
and [__] I can ask him all the questions
I didn't ask him when he was alive
like uh
Dad should I start smoking weed
never thought that is it a cheat to just
be like yeah uh Captain Kirk uh Mr Spock
like just give me those guys they know
how to Pilot Starships they're already
doing that never get lost just as long
as you don't choose the [__] uh what
were they called
um it's the far out Space Nuts yeah like
what is Leslie Knope gonna do in the
bridge of a Starship that James Kirk
couldn't
other than make us feel a bit better
about failure Rich Kirk are you grabbing
though
I grab a Wrath of Concord
I always love how [__] like when he's
wearing his glasses like it's coming in
now come
you have to learn why things weren't
going to Starship yes right on quoting
regulation Mr Saturn indeed I'll argue
against that because if I am piloting a
Starship
the entire time first off Kirk is going
to be stealing all the Starship ladies
and two he's going to be gunning for my
job and I don't need that kind of
pressure if I'm already piloting a
Starship I don't want any Adamas or Han
solos or anybody with an ego I want baby
Groot
medium Groot and brute Groot because
they're so loyal I want I want three
groots did you call them root Groot
brute Groot It's like because he's the
big trailer he's like when he's all
swollen yeah brute Groot
yeah I mean I I buy that I just don't
buy like
[__] president Bartlett as my captain
because he's got no experience I don't
have to teach a dude to like pilot a
Starship
Mike Rios and Chad I think just he sent
this with a question mark and it might
be directed our way hipster alfalfa
oh
you perhaps it's it's my hair because
it's more hair it should be a mohawk but
when I put the headphones on it squashes
it so it's more than 10 times I think
it's hot that he called you a hipster
is that have you ever thought of
yourself as a hipster
oh I wear like
like
where's scum and villainy t-shirts and
like that's it
like Jar Jar Binks unironically like
it's not
unironically yeah you're not the guy who
shows up at a Starbucks carrying an old
[__] Smith Corona typewriter
um all right man so did we get enough
people on our Starship Cruise
um I think so it's a little nebulous of
a question but
uh Ryan schwabel said emo Alfalfa get it
right
I don't think of you as emo either no
what's his name is back in a big bad way
with that [__] show short short my
God good for him
um E.T drum Mike said no he's cool Ed
Grimley oh look at you
thanks
um
also Kevin you said Jesus Christ and
everybody knows Jesus is their co-pilot
so I think that helps
good [__] point that's true we'll
never get lost with Jesus
um all right
third question answer we these question
three
uh we may have done this in the past but
we'll do it again uh endless music wants
to know what minor Star Wars character
would you like to make a series about
what minor Star Wars character yeah
Porkins
like pre-deaths like pre-rebellion
Porkins or like joining the Rebellion or
like
I barely fit in my ship porkids how does
a heavyset gentleman become such a key
member of the Rebellion you know I felt
as a kid I felt seen by that character
so
for those of uh those of us who uh you
know
have had a hard time not stopping eating
uh I think Porkins is the hero we all
need
and want to see maybe he's a failed uh
he failed out of the Empire and [__]
because they're like you don't make the
weight limit and [__] like sometimes
they bounce you out the Army if they
[__] do a surprise weigh-in and
you're too heavy and [__] maybe that's
what happened to him with the Empire and
he's just so [__] mad he went and
join the rebellion and [__] and then he
then he's firing [__] throw me out
call me fat will you
um R5 D4 get a lot of action and uh the
cartoons he's in Mando now though he is
uh he is
um
what's her face from clerks three
she has him now hey Mr she has R5 D4
yeah because she like makes a motivator
joke and stuff about him
that's right that's right and you can
actually see they like painted on the
like Scorch marks from where he blows up
earlier
kind of dope look at that deep cut
somebody in chat was like I guess deep
Cuts is anything over 10 years old yeah
in this [__] culture where we're now
drowning in content
I say yeah is it raining
um I'm not sure
nice clear and sunny in that [__]
room with a view [__] Merchant and ivory
are both like
um all right what about you
um I I kind of want to do uh the the
sitcom about the the bartender at the
Cantina
the like absurdly oddly racist bartender
at the Cantina who's just like we don't
like your kind we don't allow you in
this bar it's like dude what did a
[__] Troy do to you but suddenly
you're just so anti-droid but to be fair
as an iPhone user so am I
nice see you still got it no oh I got
bad jokes when I had weed I was The
Cutting Edge but without weed nothing
but Dad jokes
um yeah I think you could do you could
do like the the All in the Family Style
sitcom with your kind of racist a little
loathsome protagonist and all of the
goodly people who come into the bar
including his friends and co-workers and
whatever so it's cheers meets All in the
Family with a with a Droid racist at the
center of it
you know everybody loves Droid racists I
like that man that's you know [__]
they used to say like the last people
you can [__] make fun of is fat
people no now you can make fun of droids
apparently
um discriminate against droids somebody
wrote something cool in here which was I
can't [__] remember now it's gone but
I was like oh that's a cool [__]
answer but away it went oh lobot what
about [__] lobot show man find out
why I started wearing them headphones
and [__]
what did he do to Vader that made him
put those [__] headphones or to Lando
he was just on his way to a [__] Rave
and [__] because I'm one of those like
quiet race
whole [__] movie he was out of Silent
disco he was like what do you need Lando
yeah whatever but inside he was like
wait for it what are we waiting for a
drop
it's pretty good man you missed your
[__] calling your your DJ doesn't
even need [__] two turntables or a
microphone me and Michael Winslet
[Laughter]
man you got an answer I want to see
boshek boshek is the guy wearing the
NASA space suit that Obi-Wan tries to
hire before he talks to Chewbacca and I
want that guy I want to see the rest of
that guy's life where he's like just
going into different bars across the
universe going
I could have been that hero I could have
been Han Solo and he just tells that
story but every time he tells the story
it's a little bit different so it's like
he's the Pete Best of the Star Wars
universe
thank you very much
um BackBeat ladies and gentlemen 1994.
a movie all about Stuart Sutcliffe I
think that was the name of the movie
wasn't it
yeah
me and Dave thank you deep Cuts it's
older than 10 years that goes back to
94. me and Dave and chat goes I missed
earlier how much did Mark hate Quantum
Mania
fair amount
Logan Mark was so angry at quantumania
all of the hair fell out of his face as
he was talking about my the jaw that I
clenched for the last two weeks has just
finally gotten rid of all my hair
uh I saw a news story this week where um
Tony Gilroy
shouted out Clerks
today for Andor because he was like uh
you know how in clerks those guys were
talking about like where the Empire came
up with all this [__] he's like we kind
of ran with that
yeah I was like [__] hey man you
stick around long enough
people are like oh yeah he did a Thing
Once
it's still shaping culture you're gonna
watch Andor now I feel like you have to
I watched like the first two episodes
three episodes and then kind of fell
behind but now absolutely now I want to
when you talked about before boshek was
in a NASA outfit he looks like he's
wearing like a traditional kind of
human space suit
that would be a [__] show worth
watching because it's like he came from
Earth
and he was like he's like [__] [__]
Rogers he came from a deep future back
into the past yes why not Buck Rogers
went to the Future this [__] went back
to the past he's like we just started
with space travel where I came from
a long time ago
it's like Colonel Taylor but in reverse
um Colonel Taylor wow wow that's deep
Cuts back to the early 70s right there
yeah baby
um they didn't have a tailor in those
new Planet of the Apes movies did they
no no I mean they're basically the new
Apes movies the the ones that uh that
Matt Reeves did
um
yeah they well actually no they
reference Colonel Taylor and his mission
in the first one with with uh James
Franco
they have a whole thing where like the
Andromeda or whatever the name of the
ship was has uh has gone off signal has
been lost in space we may never see
Colonel Taylor again and then that's it
like it just [__] spins off that way
so connects now the Apes movies are
owned by Disney now right yeah part of
fox when do you think we get to see
another Apes movie I know they're making
another one they are they are yeah with
what's his name uh no it's not matters
it's not heavy circus anymore
um I think it's I think they want to
leave the Caesar story behind
and uh it's like there's got to be more
ape stories there's a whole [__] hate
world I think it's called Kingdom right
Kingdom of yeah
Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes
I mean
it's a little
it's a mouthful
Kingdom of the Apes works just fine and
at that point you don't really need the
planet of part but I guess that's a part
of their franchise and [__]
yeah I remember pitching on that
um at this point now like four years ago
I think
um and I pitched a version that was
mostly set in Vegas I was like I want to
see what happens when [__] Apes take
over when whatever Zoo they had in Vegas
gets taken over
and then you know all the people die and
so the ape this ape stronghold is
actually the Vegas Strip like that's fun
so it's like are the worst vices of man
the same as they are for Apes look be an
AP tonight
[Music]
um my name is Zera she was a show girl
doubt barisha says Marvel just announced
a new Apes comic book
so clearly the way is being paved I mean
just in a world of like you know IP
coming back and coming back seems weird
that we haven't had an Apes movie in a
minute
everything old is New Again
uh Michael Morales and Chad is asking
can we have a pony show during clerks
open all night
no Clerk's open all night happens on
March 10th kids that's mod Castle
Cinemas and uh we're gonna watch uh
clerks clerks two and clerks three
between
uh midnight and 6 a.m in the morning and
[__] it's gonna be a good time people
are gonna be there in their pajamas
it's gonna be a pajama party wow that
sounds fun come on out March 15th to the
17th for the Ides of Mark we're showing
uh Dune David Lynch Dune we're showing
Streets of Fire we're showing Flash
Gordon and then right after that we're
going to be doing the very first Batman
Beyond at uh smog Castle Cinemas now the
first one on the east coast we've never
done we've never done it before yeah
um tickets at smog
castlecinemas.com kids uh don't forget
Saturday night March 4th if you're
anywhere near New York City Cinema
Village wrong reasons Josh Rausch ends
his tour right there at Cinema Village
man uh 11 o'clock Show tickets are like
five bucks what do you how can you not
go
for five bucks you should buy a ticket
regardless of whether you're going or
not
just for the good of mankind yeah
Heavens man support DIY film for
heaven's sakes uh if you're going to be
in the Detroit area on uh Saturday
I will be there for uh astronomicon with
the entire
lurks World lots of clerkses lots of
Mall Rats are gonna be there yeah Jason
Lee Joey Lauren Adams Jason Muse Kevin
Smith
Harley Quinn Smith uh Brian o'holland
Jeff Anderson of the list goes on
uh it's taking place at Burton Manor
Yeah March 3rd through the 5th I'm only
there on Saturday
because on Sunday albeit's mod Castle
Cinemas showing
fat man beyond film series uh Batman
mask of the Phantasm look at that
[__] dark Nate
art man so beautiful
damn beautiful he always does such a
nice job on our artwork tickets at
smartcastlecinemas.com and Mark
Bernardin is going to be at Jay and
silly Bob's secret stash a 26 year old
brick and mortar comic book store in Red
Bank New Jersey
uh doing a signing for his book Adora in
the distance as well as anything else
he's ever worked on man do you want to
Fan out about quantumania well don't go
to [__] games
come on down let's [__] on it together
uh Victor Venn diagram and Chad wanted
to know if I was planning to show
Splinter at Kevin's theater what a great
question I was going to ask you that
earlier can you not because of the uh
thing
I mean I don't know what I can or cannot
do and I can't promise that anything
will or when will it happen if one buys
tickets to Fat Man Beyond on that Friday
night then well teased and you know I
mean we'll all be there but I don't know
we'll be used it could be that we're all
gonna be watching a little bit of
Splinter action Maybe
could happen you know enter a splinter
if you will what's the running time down
to now
um we're at 15 minutes
including credits how can I look at that
Mark wants to make a movie by the time
he was 15 he did it we did it you guys
we all did it there it is man yeah with
everybody's up I remember that oh yeah
uh Banff man you got anything you want
to plug
uh yeah and I don't know I'll just talk
about it because why not
um we are teaming up with uh the LA Phil
again to do a lot of really really cool
stuff this summer
but on April 25th they are showing
let me make sure I can I think I can
talk about this let me make sure I can
talk about this uh before I ruin
something and ruin a really good
partnership uh I think I can
yes okay great at the Walt Disney
Concert Hall we did it for Home Alone
um back in December they're going to be
showing psycho with uh live Orchestra
and I scum and villain will be there
yeah
um
so we will be there I I'm gonna we'll be
we've got a promo code coming I don't
think it's that ready yet uh but we'll
be there
um doing red wine tasting Skywalker
Pinot Noir tasting and uh horror movie
trivia for fabulous prizes I will be
hosting that with uh one of my friends
because I don't know anything about
scary movies
so
nice so that's I think that's all I've
got that's all we've got about you mark
uh I got I got nothing to plug or
promote other than all the things you've
already plugged and promoted
um
yeah I think that's it I think that's it
oh if you if you wanted to watch
um Carnival row season two it is it is
currently on Amazon's
um I worked on a version of that show
um the version that's currently on on
Amazon is I don't think the version that
I worked on but
much as such is the way of Television
these days where uh sometimes you could
you could spend half a year working on a
thing and not recognize any of it not
saying it's good bad or indifferent just
I don't know what it is now but if you
want to check it out go for it
um and you should also if you're a Star
Trek fan at all
um watch Picard the third and final
season of Picard Star Trek Picard
um I had nothing to do with it other
than just being a fan of it and so far
it is the the Next Generation sort of uh
mounting up of the old guys that you
always kind of wanted so enjoy I am
Victor Venn diagram in chat asked JC can
you post a link for tickets to the thing
you talked about
he said I am interested in that well
Victor are you also interested in
Hollywood Babylon March 18th that
Flappers Comedy Club tickets at Flappers
comedy club.com uh I will be back in Los
Angeles on the 18th for some of that but
prior to that it's all East Coast Action
Man
ask of the Phantasm March 5th uh even
the day before that uh wrong reasons
finishes up its tour at Cinema Village
in New York tickets at findcat odin.com
uh tickets for The Ides of Mark which
runs from March 15th to March 17th
tickets at smartcastlecinemas.com Mark
gonna be signing at Jay and Silent Bob's
secret stash on March 18th no tickets
just show up and bring some [__] whip
out your dick he'll sign it you just got
stretch it he won't stretch it no
stretch it
you get a friend if you need he'll hold
the pen like way high up so he doesn't
even close to your [__] like you know
most people hold [__] like that but that
put it real close so he's going to be
signing like this if you whip your dick
out yeah Dora he'll sign that normal
style I will I won't stabs on dick if
you don't want to
[__] dick
s uh Davey sock rocker what a great name
so don't have this long of gaps in fat
man beyond it was hard to deal with uh
that'd be my bad I was uh I was gone for
a month kids and one day perhaps I'll
talk about it but right now I'm back
that's all that matters and here we are
having a good ass time
uh NWR
ndrwlbr says Kevin you look so good you
look so good man looking healthy why
thank you feeling healthy
what was the line from [__] Trading
Places looking good looking good Louis
was feeling good
Billy Ray Every Witch can but Loose have
you watched um you people on Netflix the
Eddie Murphy uh no is it any good I
haven't seen it yet but I want to see it
yeah I'm currently too busy watching
um the [__] is the name of this thing
hold on I gotta find it I'm watching
your honor have you seen your honor this
season
good Showtime show holy [__] they did a
show it was like two years ago they ran
it and it was [__] astounding I was
like the ending is is just such a
[__]
satisfying yet heartbreaking conclusion
and [__] and I never imagined that they
would do a season two I was like this is
a complete [__] story and they found
a way
to do a season two man it's it's been
[__] really good Brian Cranston is so
fantastic and the whole cast is great
what's that dude's name Michael stolberg
yeah oh he's great oh I [__] love
that guy and everything and he plays a
[__] mobster in this and he's like
one of the least mobster dudes like in
every other movie you've ever seen but
[__] is he good in this man oh cast is
great that shows that shows the truth
man go check out your honor on Showtime
yeah I've been I I fell off of the
yellow jackets wagon the first go-around
so now I'm I'm
finally finishing season one in the end
of season two isn't that a great show a
[__] killer cast and I just saw the
trailer for season two's coming up
just just in time I'm getting under the
wire but don't forget tonight kids uh
it's the Mandalorian is back Mando
that's right we're gonna see [__]
dudes in armor flying and not taking
their helmets off or paying the price
for taking their helmets off indeed
it'll be spot the Pedro see if you can
find the one time he's on that set
J A t-bug says Kevin quit smoking weed
because he is on probation now for
carrying on a plane no I never got in
trouble for weed man like I got pulled
over
a few times and they found weed in the
car and they're like get out of here
Simon Bob so
look I never got arrested for carrying
weed I'm a white man
[Music]
oh my God it's my privilege
I didn't think I was white I just
thought I was a quasi celebrity but
dude did I ever tell the story about
when I got pulled over
I got pulled over coming down Highland
and I was making a right onto the street
to like go up and over the hill to your
house and uh because I guess there's no
right turn during morning Rush Hour
and I got pulled over and the cop came
up he's like you know there's no right
turn he's like you know your windows are
illegally tinted and I have like a Dodge
Challenger with like blacked out windows
like I
I am the car that everybody wants every
cop wants to pull over and I was like
I'm so sorry I'm going to my boss's
house for a video shoot and the guy's
like
I was like Kevin Smith he's like yeah
right
and then Muse Drives By right at that
moment stops right behind the car rolls
down the window and goes haha you're
gonna be late to work sucker and sped
off the cop looked at Jay of Jay and
Silent Bob and looked at me and just
goes okay you can go oh give me a ticket
it's privilege
the the tangential effects of proximity
to fame
um uh the some people are saying hey man
what happened uh I can't find tickets to
uh The Ides of Mark it's Monica
cinemas.com if it's not up tonight it'll
be up tomorrow morning uh JD our web guy
was
we hit him very late and stuff we just
got him the finished artwork which we
had to switch around but uh don't worry
those tickets will be up there you could
hit it tomorrow don't quit it hit it get
your tickets for the odds of Market
Heavens we'll have so much fun uh are we
done we should be we're done
we're at a show there it is kids we're
at a show we gave you all the show we
can it's all the shows I can stand
because I can't stand no more to borrow
from Popeye do the right thing do the
right thing says Christopher Morris
you're the right King oh my God that
[__] rocks I got it I'm gone
um okay uh
don't forget to patronize Banff Man's
Bar scum and villainy cantina I may be
in there tomorrow night just cause who
you me
you're coming withdrawal from not being
in [__] scum and villainy for the
last six months so you're just gonna sit
in a booth and drink alone and chill I'm
just gonna give me some [__] tater
tots and a wakanda forever and see what
happens
I'll be hosting
I'm hosting trivia tomorrow so come soon
it's trivia night um
[__] love that man
um well there it is kids there's your
fat man be on for this week uh we'll be
getting back into a fairly regular
schedule
oh yeah don't you worry about what the
what is on my mustache have I been doing
a show with [__] [__] on my mustache
the whole time I just thought it was the
sparkle lavender
it could very well be let's find out
I think it is oh my God kids this is
just straight up Bulgarian lavender man
I bought it on the streets for a hundred
dollars a bottle did I paid too much I
don't give a [__]
do they make the good lavender and
Bulgarian
lavender comes from apparently
um yeah man I feel calm because lavender
yeah
it's like yeah now I got this great
Himalayan sea salt like all salted sea
salt you guys
only though the only [__] Lavender in
the world comes from Bulgaria like no
that's not true
three four syllable word they put in
front of lavender to make you pay more
at Whole Foods and it worked they start
making shitty Russian cars and now they
just export lavender
so calming excellent so coming uh there
it is my friends
uh give it up for uh the guy who's in
the other box without whom there is no
[__] show Mr Mark Bernardin thank you
sir always good to have you back uh give
it up for Banff Man without a without
whom really there is no show me Martin
just talking to each other on [__] I
chat or some such [__] we're just having
a zoom we're just blooming at each other
who's zooming who it'd be me and Mark
thank God uh JC make sure that we're all
[__] seen and a lot somebody said you
look like Jim Jefferies tonight
yes not a deep cut but a good cut it'll
work
um emo Alfalfa may win the evening
though although it doesn't make sense
yeah it's hardly even
cool leg grimly
OLED Grimley may be the winner uh don't
forget like Mark said go see quantumania
please they need all the help like again
those Independent films boy they can
really use your help uh and there it is
folks there's your fat man beyond for
this week uh for fat man beyond
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard tune in
next time same that time same fat
channels modcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's a kiss ladies and
gentlemen
good night kids
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]